c'est un rêve d'enfant qui tourne au
cauchemar à amboise le conservatoire de
la confiserie est en passe de mettre la
clé sous la porte cet atelier musée
consacré aux métiers de confiseurs fait
les frais des fermetures liées au
confinement le fondateur de l'entreprise
cumule 114 mille euros de loyers impayés
le propriétaire des lieux a demandé son
expulsion
quand l' aventure d'une vie tourne au
cref coeur c'est un reportage de tristan
rickli
chaque jour nicolas élabore ses
confiseries étape par étape les bonbons
prennent forme sous l'oeil émerveillé
des visiteurs
c'est la première fois qu'on voit
fabriquer des bonbons comme ça sur place
et puis en plus va c'est chez nous quoi
donc c'est quand même une bonne chose je
suis quand même impressionné par le
nombre de deux machines qu'il ya mais le
plaisir pourraient être de courte durée
l'entreprise pourrait fermer ses portes
avant la fin de l'année ce serait
dommage que ça ferme parce que c'est ça
peut servir pour beaucoup de choses pour
l'enseignement etc
problème les dettes se sont accumulées
pendant les périodes de confinement sans
activité niet de l'état nicolas ne peut
rembourser les 114 mille euros de loyers
réclamé par son bailleur j'ai donc
emménagé fin 2010 9,2 les locaux pour
une ouverture début 2020 mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé demi des débuts 2020
c'est le co vide donc confinement
suspension donc des financements
on se retrouve démuni pas de possibilité
d'avoir deux trésoriers pas de soutiens
pas dead la sphère est passé devant la
justice le risque à présent l'expulsion
et la saisie de tout ce qu'il a investi
pour lui le rêve s'est brisé
l'engagement de toute une vie depuis
l'âge de 14 ans je collectionne le
matériel j'ai toujours été de ce milieu
là et c'est ma vie qu'en fin de compte
le clash est en train de tout perdre
touché par son histoire un collectif
d'amboise hien a décidé de lui venir en
aide pour soutenir la confiserie on a
pensé mettre en place et on va mettre en
place des 6e soins une cagnotte une
cagnotte litchi donc pour que les gens
puissent donner un petit peu afin que
nicolas tu puisses faire c'est une somme
en vue éventuellement d'arrêter une
procédure si le dernier espoir de
nicolas pour maintenir son activité